president biden's massive social
spending plan is being delayed until the
new year this is the latest setback for
his agenda as he heads to south carolina
to deliver a speech white house
officials say democrats still do not
have enough votes to pass a bill that
would expand the government safety net
other proposals to target to target
rather immigration voting rights are
also stalled wijajang is at the white
house with more on this story wija good
morning to you good morning to you gail
and good morning to everybody in a new
statement president biden acknowledged
that it would take days or weeks to
advance that bill cbs news has learned
that negotiations between the president
and west virginia senator joe manchin a
key democratic vote were going poorly
last night despite having to push back
the self-imposed christmas deadline mr
biden insisted manchin recently
reiterated his support for the nearly
two trillion dollar plan it would lower
prescription drug prices expand health
and child care and tackle climate change
but in a blow to democrats yesterday a
senate parliamentarian ruled that it
could not include new immigration
policies like work authorization and
deportation protections now the path
forward there will almost certainly
require republican support which is
unlikely that's also the case for the
president's voting rights legislation
which mr biden has called the single
biggest domestic issue he led a call
with senators yesterday on voting rights
but democrats would likely need to
change senate rules to make any progress
on that front so it is a heavy lift
across the board tony
weisha thank you very much